what's popping Sky guys it's me Mt and
welcome back to the heavy spoiler show
Ahsoka episode 3 gifted us with one of
the most badass moments in Star Wars
history with Ahsoka taking down a
Starship in space in style but the
question Still Remains will her Padawan
Sabine ever get that good will she ever
hope to get that good also who the hell
is this mysterious Merrick guy anyway
let's dive into both of these big
questions together my nerd babies but
let's start with the Padawan who Yang
loves to bully first by answering the
question does Sabine actually possess
the force inside of her and the simple
answer to that question is yes in fact
according to George Lucas himself every
single living being in the galaxy has
the force living inside of them Lucas
says a lot of people get confused about
the force they see it as some special
thing that you find and pick up and put
it on your head and suddenly you have
the force whereas it's always been
designed so that every living being has
the force the amount of force which is
like Talent OR intelligence is different
in every person some of it is inherited
but it's no more than a talent it's not
something that you can acquire it's
something you can learn to use I have
the power to lift that cop off the table
using the force but I can't do it unless
I have been trained to do it end quote
because the force is the very invisible
energy field that binds all of life in
the very Galaxy together the force
resides in every single living being
even animals it simply boils down to a
person having the professional guidance
to be able to tap into their own inner
power and some people are born more
blessed than other people due to having
a higher presence of little microscopic
organisms in their blood called midi
glorians yes yes I know I just said the
m word without the M wordpass from the
internet but as controversial as the
concept of midichlorians are they're
actually super important to the science
of wielding the force in general in the
Star Wars Universe because these little
microbes that exist in every single
living being in the Star Wars Galaxy
have a direct connection to the force
itself and the more of them a person has
in their body the easier it will be for
them to connect to the force young
Anakin Skywalker in The Phantom Menace
is the best example of this as his
ridiculously high midichlorian count is
what led him to be able to tap into the
force without any draining like that kid
would not have been able to win that pod
race or have been able to blow up the
droid control ship over Naboo without
that cellular advantage of having a
midichlorian count higher than Master
Yoda himself and it's an advantage that
his children Luke and Leia and his
grandson Ben all share through genetics
this all being said though Sabine
doesn't have a high midichlorian count
of 27 000 like Anakin Skywalker did she
like every living being does have
midi-chlorians living inside of her
cells she just very likely doesn't have
a whole lot to make her as naturally
talented as Anakin Skywalker or any of
the other Jedi of the Fallen Jedi Order
because the Jedi literally went out to
look for children with high midichlorian
counts this is the significance of
grogu's existence in the Mandalorian the
Empire with the help of Dr Pershing was
experimenting with the high amount of
midichlorians in grogu's Blood on the
road to eventually producing the
insanely powerful Dark Side clone known
as supreme leader snoke as well as moth
Gideon's production of Gideon clones
with the power to tap into the force
something the original Mark Gideon could
not do thanks to him being born with a
low midichlorian count much like Sabine
was however despite this Sabine can
still learn how to tap into the force
using the midichlorians within her own
self as long as she learned how to stop
letting her fears and frustrations lead
her to self-doubt which is why I believe
that Ahsoka tells huyang that she
doesn't need Sabine to be a Jedi but to
just be herself instead to have faith in
the little midichlorians that she does
have to be able to tap into the force
that runs through her body Sabine just
needs to conquer her fear of being too
weak to protect her family after losing
her Rebel family members Ezra and Kanan
as well as being largely responsible for
developing the technology that led to
the enslaving of her Mandalorian people
this is just like when we saw Obi-Wan
lose his connection to the force at the
start of his show because his fear of
the Empire and other people in general
caused him to doubt himself and his
abilities with his faith only being
restored after Leia gave him a reason to
be more hopeful than fearful again but
anyways let's talk Merrick specifically
about some theories as to who this man
behind the mask could be all we know
about Merrick so far is that they used
to be a former Inquisitor for the Empire
now hired as a mercenary for the dark
Morgan elsbeth alongside the bearded
Balin skull and the slashing shin-hati
and that the names of all three of these
dark side Warriors have links to
mythical Wolves of Legend with Valen's
skull and shinhati both being references
to two mythical Wolves of North
mythology named skull and hottie and
Merrick seemingly being a reference to
the werewolf Knight of King Arthur's
Round Table sir Merrick so this being
the case I can definitely see why a lot
of Ahsoka fans on the internet have been
theorizing that the Merrick under the
mask is none other than the miss sing
Ezra Bridger as Ezra's ties to lothal
and the force connected loath Wolves of
that planet very much lend themselves to
a werewolf name like Merrick as it would
match up very well with the overall Wolf
theme that these Three aggro Amigos of
Ahsoka got going on and with Merrick's
use of a voice changer it's not entirely
out of the question to assume that
lucasfilm could be disguising Ezra's
voice as a surprise as soon as Merrick
takes off that mask because typically in
media voice changers are used to mask
voices of past established characters
that the audience is at least somewhat
familiar with in some way however one
thing that this theory has going against
it is that Ezra has never had a career
as a Jedi hunting exterminator
Inquisitor before he went whale surfing
in the stars and the rebels finale so
there would have to be a pretty damn
good explanation for the massive change
of heart and loyalties by the end of the
show because as we're turning to the
dark side and becoming an Inquisitor
which sort of kind of cheapened his
selfless sacrifice in rebels in my
opinion but that's just one possibility
with a name like Merrick it's also
unsurprising to see that the other
prevailing theory on the internet for
this dark Warrior's identity is rooted
in none other than Mr Galen Merrick
himself also known as Starkiller Darth
Vader's former cloned apprentice and the
Legends Canon if you've ever played the
Force Unleashed video games then you
would know that Starkiller did act as an
Inquisitor of sorts for his master Darth
Vader as he was tasked to go on a series
of secret undercover missions for Vader
that led him to assassinating Jedi
Knights on the run like Shakti and
kazden Paratus after becoming a fast
favorite fans of the Force Unleashed
video games were super bummed to find
out that all of those games were no
longer Canon following Disney's
acquisition of the Star Wars property
however with the recent reintroduction
of elements of the Legends Canon slowly
creeping into the modern Star Wars
narrative a new introduction for
Starkiller would not be out of the
question especially considering that
Ahsoka is a story revolving around Grand
Admiral thrawn another character from
The Legends continuity that Star Wars
Rebels seemingly revived for their
upcoming adaptation of the heir to the
Empire story that is reportedly coming
very soon Dave filoni and the Gang at
lucasfilm seem to be perfectly fine with
digging into the Legends Canon for some
inspiration I mean hell lucasfilm even
had Hera name her son Jason sindula
seemingly as a shout out to Hanan Leia's
Evil Darkside son from The Legends Canon
Jason solo so Starkiller Darth Vader's
apprentice being recanonized in a new
way as an Inquisitor in a show about
Anakin Skywalker's Apprentice Ahsoka
would be extremely appropriate as it
would be exciting to see these two
apprentices Clash especially since the
last season of the Mandalorian has
recently underscored the Empire's
interest in revitalizing the cloning
program a program that Galen Merrick was
a product of himself in the Force
Unleashed too first with the story of
Clone Dr pershing's betrayal at the
hands of secret Imperial loyalist Elia
Kane and then wrapping up the season
with the revelation of MAF Gideon
manufacturing an army of force-wielding
Giancarlo espositos but then an
explosion caused all those espositos to
get delete those but while Ezra and
Starkiller are the most popular guesses
for Merrick's identity I think the
Ahsoka narrative allows for a few more
potential contenders contenders like the
much forgotten Inquisitor who has the
most beef with Ahsoka herself the sixth
brother Bill Valen because you see those
two fancy white lightsabers that Ahsoka
used during that six ship clipping space
flip there's actually a story about how
she got those within the 2016 Ahsoka
novel in that book we learned that
ahsoka's kyber crystals in her two
lightsabers didn't always glow white but
used to glow red when they belong to the
bloodthirsty Inquisitor the sixth
brother after being ruthlessly hunted by
the sixth brother in that book their
last confrontation ended with Ahsoka
exploding the sixth Brothers lightsaber
directly in front of his face leading to
what we are led to assume was his demise
but what if the sick brother did not die
what if the sixth brother in his new
Despicable face survived and have been
plotting revenge against Ahsoka for
stealing and purifying his two red kyber
crystals into the two white kreiber
crystals after their battle I mean if
the grand Inquisitor and Riva can both
survive fatal wounds using the sheer
anger in their hearts to sustain them
that is technically possible for the
sixth brother to do this too the dark
side of the force is a gateway to
abilities some could considered to be
unnatural after all now this all being
said and considering that the Inquisitor
Merrick has a voice changer as well as a
mask completely covering his face at all
times having Merrick being revealed as
the sixth brother having his life
sustained by a suit of Technology like
Darth Vader would be a clever way for
the Ahsoka series to give Ahsoka a
nemesis while also serving as an
explanation for where ahsoka's white
lightsabers even came from because there
was a very large section of the Star
Wars audience who have likely not gotten
around to reading that Ahsoka book yet I
can totally see the sixth brother
looking for revenge against Ahsoka for
Wrecking his face and stealing his magic
murder rocks especially knowing that the
Ahsoka novel mainly refers to the sixth
brother as a creature rather than a
person due to the six brothers
gray-skinned alien race being completely
unknown to anyone in that novel it's
like a mystery race with sir Merrick
from the King Arthur Legend being a
creature himself having the sixth
brother give himself a name like Merrick
would be thematically appropriate
however there is still another Star Wars
character that would fit into the
overall Wolf theme of this Trio of
antagonists and it's kind of a crazy one
so I'm gonna need you guys to buckle up
and hear me out for this one because I
completely recognize how insane what I'm
about to say might sound at first this
is a crazy Theory the wild Theory just
go with me here because I think that
there could be a a slight chance here
that Merrick could be none other than
Kanan and Hera's son Jason yeah that
little green-haired boy that was just
introduced in live action in that last
episode of Ahsoka whose name again is a
clear reference to the dark sided Jason
solo from the Legends continuity and
there are a few reasons why I think this
first for these reasons being that Jason
perfectly fits under the Wolf theme as
the son of Kanan Jairus a Jedi closely
affiliated with the loath wolf Animal
native to lothal I mean hell after
cooking himself alive to save his
friends Kanan appears to have been
reborn in the form of a loath wolf named
Doom that guides Ezra on his journey so
since Jason's father is symbolically a
wolf this would make Jason symbolically
half wolf much like a werewolf like sir
Merrick the knight in King Arthur's tale
is but obviously that is not enough to
explain how some green-haired little boy
who wishes he could be a Jedi could
possibly lead a secret double life as an
Evil Darkside mercenary at the same time
well I believe that there is a slight
and super wild chance here that Merrick
could possibly end up being Jason from
the future and that this adult Jason
secretly wants to make sure that the kid
Jason version of himself travels to the
past to be brainwashed by Palpatine's
Inquisition and become Merrick by
tempting his younger self with a way to
try to save his father Kanan from dying
and this is where the concept of time
travel comes in a concept tightly
associated with Ahsoka the person as
well as the very design of the Ahsoka
show logo if you watched my last Ahsoka
video going over the first two episodes
I bring up the idea that the Ahsoka logo
itself being purposely modeled after the
world Between Worlds the cosmic shortcut
through time and space manifested By The
Cosmic force that Ezra uses to save
ahsoka's life from Vader's clutches in
Star Wars Rebels with the blue
background of the logo representing the
galaxies of the cosmos and the white
letters in front of it representing the
world Between Worlds itself with the two
letter A's and the O representing the
Triangular and circular gateways I
believe that this is a massive piece of
symbolic foreshadowing for a possible
return to the world Between Worlds for
Ahsoka at some point this season
especially since the star map temple on
Arcana seems to have strong ties to the
mortise God Trinity of force gods that
guard the world Between Worlds through
temples across the cosmos and since
episode 2 of Ahsoka already confirmed
that light time manipulation elements
are already in play through Morgan
elsby's magic messages from throm that
transcend time itself it seems to
indicate that thrawn is fated to
discover a gateway to the world Between
Worlds within a temple on the far away
planet of paridia now if that were to
happen and Ahsoka and the rebels gang
somehow find another gateway to the
world Between Worlds in an ancient Force
temple on the planet paridia that I
could potentially see Jason being
tempted with the idea of saving his
father much like Ezra was because Jason
really wants to become a Jedi and his
father could teach him how to be that if
this child Jason were to step through
one of these gateways and accidentally
find himself lost in a time period of
Palpatine's Grand Inquisition the
chances of of a young Jason being found
by Palpatine's people and converted into
an Inquisitor himself is quite high in
my opinion as Palpatine was very
interested in recruiting young children
like Riva and using torture to make them
his loyal soldiers so if Merrick were to
manipulate or even convince Jason to go
back in time to be molded into an
Inquisitor by tempting this young Jason
with a way to cheat death Merrick would
have successfully used the world Between
Worlds to ensure his own descent into
the dark side because as soon as kid
Jason were to get lost in the past
Ahsoka would be powerless to do anything
about it as she is completely against
using the world Between Worlds to alter
history but that's just my assessment on
Sabine in morocc let us know what you
guys think in the comment section below
but anyways thank you guys so much for
watching this video you can follow me at
Mass retainment on Twitter or Instagram
or wherever I am on the internet so if
you guys want to see me post some weird
but most importantly do not forget
to subscribe to heavy spoilers because
we've got some really great things for
you guys all the time because we love
you guys so anyways thank you guys again
for watching and I'll see you guys later
goodbye